Cristóbal contanos Por qué están
enviando a los migrantes a la casa de la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris
al observatorio naval precisamente
porque es la casa de kamala Harris y
kamala Harris fue designada por el
presidente Joe para precisamente lidiar
esta encargada de trabajar y de
encontrar soluciones a la crisis
migratoria que vivió Estados Unidos
crisis migratoria que de hecho kamala
Harris niega Y esto es lo que pues ha
aprendido un poco a los gobernadores de
los estados del sur para enviar estos
migrantes a la casa de kamala Harris
llegaron por la mañana de este sábado
fueron rápidamente acogidos por la
ciudad de Washington y albergados en
lugares donde les van a proveer
servicios médicos y comida al respecto
el presidente ha criticado estas medidas
diciendo que la crisis migratoria está
siendo usada como una herramienta
política por parte de los republicanos
los republicanos por su parte se quejan
de que precisamente no se le ha puesto
la atención suficiente a esta crisis
migratoria que muy bien los estados del
sur Cristóbal hablemos de un tema que no
es para nada menor y que afecta
muchísimo por supuesto a estos estados
que es el costo no lo que están ganando
los estados y los que están gastando
Perdón los estados y los gobernadores
con estas medidas
claro además a estos migrantes les
prometen les prometen todo tipo de
beneficios una vez lleguen a estas
ciudades del Norte ciudad de santuarios
trabajo vivienda y mejores condiciones
de vida se calcula que cerca de 12
millones de dólares solamente Texas ha
gastado enviando migrantes además se
calcula que ya son más de 20.000
migrantes indocumentados los que Texas
Arizona y la Florida han enviado a
ciudades santuario como Nueva York como
Chicago y como Washington Washington sin
embargo ha sido una de las más afectadas
con más de 10.000 inmigrantes y de hecho
la alcaldesa ya ha declarado el estado
de emergencia en esta